[MUSIC PLAYING]
The Glass Lab started in
1986, at least the Glass Lab
as we know it today.
That's when I started at MIT,
a professor in the Material
Science Department
approached me and said,
I have a lab in building
4, would you like it?
And, not knowing what was
in it, I just said yes.
And thinking that I was going
to turn it into a research lab.
But before I had a chance
to even visit the lab,
I was approached by two
students and a glass artist
from outside of MIT to
use the glass furnace
in the lab that had been there.
It hadn't been
used in many years,
but they wanted to
turn it on, and I
didn't know what
glassblowing was,
so I learned with great
difficulty how to blow glass.
And, at the same time,
I approached the School
of Engineering for funding
to do the renovation
in the laboratory to
turn it into a hot shop
That was at a time when
MIT was particularly
concerned about innovation
and teaching innovation
across the campus.
And the pitch
became, this is a way
that students can learn
to improvise together.
It's one of the few
craft arts that you
have to work in a team.
And one thing led to another.
We began teaching first an
IAP course, and then seminars.
And soon it became the most
oversubscribed class at MIT.
Yeah, so I heard about it at
the beginning of freshman year,
and I entered in the
lottery over IAP,
which is during January,
and I didn't get in.
But I really wanted
to take this class.
So I signed up for the
lottery again in the spring,
and I guess I was one of
the lucky few that got it.
This is such an
amazing opportunity.
I've been really
interested in glassblowing.
I knew that coming
here would be something
that I would want to do.
I definitely want to take
more classes in the future.
I want to take a couple
of more beginner classes,
and then maybe move on to
the intermediate level.
The Glass Lab is a place at MIT
where people can come and use
their hands to do things.
And it's one of the
few places where
you can go and build things
and learn about things that
are part of the curriculum in
some way, but learn about it
the way your hand
and body picks it up,
instead of strictly
intellectually.
We encourage a lot
cross-disciplinary play
in the lab.
That's the thing that-- where
the biggest amount of juice
comes out, in my experience,
when students make connections
between using the material
and things that they're
learning in other situations.
The Glass Lab draws people
from all over the Institute.
In fact, it's designed that way.
It's a non-credit activity.
We've always believed--
if we offer credit,
then only certain majors
will be able to take
advantage of that facility.
So we kept credit
out of the picture,
primarily because it's so
important for students at MIT
to meet people from other
places at the Institute.
And not only meet them,
but work with them.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
An example of
something unique that's
come out of the Glass
Lab is the glass band
that's come out this past year.
[PLAYING GLASS FLUTE]
As a beginner in the
glass blowing program,
I think I was really excited
to get more involved.
And music was something that
was very important to me
at the time.
I'd been playing flute for
10 years at that point.
So I thought it'd be
really exciting to delve
into this project with them.
At the same time,
though, being MIT,
I felt like we could
push it toward something
a little bit more exciting.
So you can order a
glass flute online.
So I thought it would be
much more interesting if we'd
take advantage of the
creative environment
and start working with more
experimental designs, both kind
of experimenting with the
mechanics and the material
interaction with the
voice of the instruments.
It festered, or I
should say incubated
for a couple of years, and
then approaching and supporting
the musical partner
about the idea of,
what if we had this
cross-disciplinary class, where
we get people from
music department,
we get somebody who's interested
in composing or helping us put
sounds together so
that we could perform?
Let's find out what
kinds of sounds glass
makes, and make something
happen with that.
So that's how this got started.
But this was a student
inspired course,
if you really think about it.
It wasn't a faculty
member driving us.
It was a student driving us.
And that's the
kind of thing that
can happen in a facility
like the Glass Lab.
That's the reason why we
have these things at MIT.
Now over 25 years of doing
it, we've seen just the impact
that that's had on graduates.
They look back on the
Glass Lab experience at MIT
as some of the most
important activities
that they've done, primarily
because of who they met
and who they've worked with.
Most do not become glass artists
when they take this course.
But they have an
experience trying
to improvise with people of all
different types of backgrounds
and capabilities.
And that's good because
everybody's learning
as we do these courses.